this story begins with the standard
level of public school degeneracy but
then gets darkened
darker and darker as you plunge down the
rabbit hole our friends over at yaf have
the report out of
bellingham school district in washington
according to an anonymous tip they
received
a first grade teacher by the name of
jennifer miller read a trans propaganda
book called i
am jazz to the six and seven-year-old
children in her first grade class
this was done apparently without asking
the parents permission or notifying them
ahead of time of course
now subscribers to my youtube channel
and if you're not a subscriber you
should become one
uh maybe familiar with the book i am
jazz because we did a video a few months
ago where i read that book and this
story out of bellingham school district
is exactly why i read it kids are being
subjected to this kind of thing
in school and it's important that you
understand what exactly we're dealing
with
more specifically what your kids are
dealing with
to summarize i am jazz tells the true
life tale
of jazz jennings a boy who began
transitioning into a girl
from the age of like four or five
because his mom is a munchausen abuser
who projected her own mania onto her
helpless little boy now that's my own
editorial
that's not what the book says exactly
what the book does say is that jazz was
a boy
with a girl stuck inside him or rather
he was a boy with a girl's brain
stuck inside him somehow now how does a
boy end up with a girl brain
what does it actually mean isn't a brain
inside a boy's head automatically a boy
a boy brain literally by definition i
mean is it like the definition of a boy
brain
uh like the the brain inside of a boy is
a boy brain isn't that what that is
well the book doesn't get into these
questions at all here's how the book
presents it i'll play a clip here of
jazz jennings himself actually reading
the book here it is let's watch
i have a girl brain but a boy body this
is called transgender
i was born this way
when i was very little and my mom would
say you're such a good boy
i would say no mama good girl
at first my family was confused they'd
always thought of me as a boy
as i got a little older i hardly ever
played with trucks
or tools or superheroes only princesses
and mermaid costumes
my brothers told me this was girl stuff
i kept right on playing
my sister says i was always talking to
her about my girl thoughts
and my girl dreams and how one day i
would be a beautiful lady
she would giggle and say you're a funny
kid
sometimes my parents let me wear my
sister's dresses around the house
but whenever we went out i had to put on
my boy clothes again
this made me mad still i never gave up
trying to convince them
pretending i was a boy felt like telling
a lie
your parents were confused his parents
were confused
i'm confused uh his parents were
confused when the boy says
uh no mommy i'm a girl and the parents
said what i'm so confused what's going
on
what's what's happening oh it's just
your kid being a kid that's what's
happening your kid
just your kid is simply babbling like
kids do
not much to be confused about
but this is what children are being
taught in school
it's the brainwashing that um first
graders in the bellingham school
district had to endure
which is what caused some parents to
email the teacher understandably
outraged and demand answers
now as yaf reports the teacher jennifer
miller responded to one email saying
yes i did read this book as a district
we are working hard to support
all members of our school community and
promote inclusion through
understanding and compassion yes
understanding she is promoting
understanding by making wild
anti-scientific claims about girl brains
getting accidentally planted inside the
skulls of little boys
maybe there's some kind of mix-up on the
assembly line in heaven i don't know
and she's promoting compassion by
normalizing the psychological and sexual
abuse of children
right makes total sense but as i warn
this story gets
even more deranged parents took their
plight to the school board
hoping to find a sane person somewhere
who would hold this pervert teacher
accountable but sadly this school board
did nothing
and that's probably because the
president of the school board is another
jennifer jennifer mason
who lists her first of all lists her
pronouns in her instagram bio so it kind
of tells you where she's coming from
but far worse than that she also runs a
self-described
all-ages sex toy shop no i didn't miss
speak
it is an all ages sex toy shop and all
ages really means
all ages reading now from the yaf report
it says an investigation by yaff
revealed that jennifer mason president
of the bellingham school
school board owns and operates a
self-described all-ages sex toy shop
according to a local paper mason said
while the store
only sells for those ages 16 and older
16 and older at the sex toy shop
people of any age can be in the store
uh i want to be i want to show people if
i want to show people if sex isn't
something to be ashamed about
um i should be able to be an elected
official and own a sex toy shop at the
same time mason told the local paper
that's what it means to live your values
well that part is true i mean she is
living her values she is living by the
values of a demented freak
and she's running the school board by
those same values
these are also the values of the most
powerful people and institutions in
america
which perhaps lends some context to a
moment yesterday that got plenty of
attention
and provoked plenty of laughter when
representative corey bush
one of the newest members of the squad i
believed addressed a house committee
and used a certain phrase let's listen
to that clip
i sit before you today as a single mom
as a nurse
as an activist and as a congresswoman
and i am committed
to doing the absolute most to protect
black mothers
to protect black babies to protect black
birthing people
and to save lives thank you and i yield
back
birthing people of course many jokes
can be made about this and have been
made about this and should be made about
this and yeah that's all good
it deserves to be mocked relentlessly
and ruthlessly
so we can of course joke about how we're
gonna call our moms on sunday to wish a
happy birthing person day or
we could start talking about how we need
to rewrite some song titles like
when a man loves a birthing person and
man i feel like a birthing person
and then you know american birthing
person and witching burst
birthing person um you get the idea all
the jokes are great but
underneath the well-deserved mockery
is a pretty insidious truth
that they're trying to rewrite reality
they're taking all that is good and true
and beautiful and they're emptying it
out
and twisting it into hideous
unrecognizable shapes
and making everything ugly and weird and
meaningless
what we need desperately to understand
and what cannot possibly be emphasized
enough
is that these people when i say these
people i mean the ones running schools
and school boards and classrooms and
state houses all the way up to congress
and the white house
they have a deep seething hatred for
all that they consider to be old and
traditional and outmoded
we could say that they don't trust any
truth that they didn't invent themselves
five seconds ago they want to break down
not only human civilization but humanity
itself
and build it all up again in their own
deranged image
they believe they have a moral license
to do whatever needs to be done in order
to bring
bring that about certainly brainwashing
your child
is one of those things that's why that
teacher when she was called on it
she didn't apologize or anything like
that she said yeah i read the book what
are you going to do about it
i'll read whatever i want to your kid
because these are my values and they're
the correct values
they don't recognize your moral or
natural authority as a parent
over your own children because you're
one of the bad guys in their minds
and they are saving your children from
you
by indoctrinating them into the cult of
the chosen ones the enlightened ones
this is what we're up against it's the
hill that we're fighting on
and it really is the last hill because
it's the hill of
reality itself that's what the battle is
over
and we really really cannot afford to
lose it
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated